let's go to your voicemail our voicemail
number is two one nine to david p we got
a voicemail today from the Eggman and
it's about shepherd smith we've been
talking about shepherd smith from fox
news for a while because he is the most
common occasional voice of reason on fox
news and when i start a story by saying
the truth was told on fox news it's
almost always Shep Smith and I've
speculated that maybe he's got a really
good contract and that's why he does
what he wants and he still works there
I've also speculated that maybe it's
because Fox News wants to have someone
they can point to and say we have a
diverse range of opinions because we've
got Shep Smith and then everybody else
and there's a third possibility I've
mentioned before which the eggman also
mentions in this voicemail take a listen
to what he had to say hey David I don't
think Fox News keeps keppard Smith on
because they're trying to look more fair
and balanced
I think Shep Smith has something on them
he's been there a long time he's got
something I mean not P P tastes good but
maybe that good yeah so I've mentioned
this before I had the privilege I would
call it I was gonna say opportunity but
really the privilege of getting to know
the late great Alan Colmes
quite well when I lived in New York City
and the David Pakman show was there we
would get together we would go to a
coffee shop he checked out david pakman
show studios i went to his studio at
foxnews and as you might remember he
very very tragically passed away a year
or a year and a half ago or something
like that and i'm speaking in very
general terms and i think that this is
really not a big deal to say at this
point he did intimated to me that Shep
did have something on individuals at Fox
News and I don't know exactly the
specifics I have general knowledge and
I'm not going to speculate because I
think that that's sort of going beyond
where I should but I'm now that I've
been reminded of that conversation I had
with Alan Colmes I am certainly open to
the possibility that Shep has something
on people at FoxNews and that that may
be part of why part of why his career on
Fox News persevered with seemingly
almost full freedom to say whatever he
wants in addition to the very nice
contract renewals that he keeps getting
we've got a great bonus show coming up
for you today we will talk about Melania
Trump's statement about the policy under
the Trump administration of separating
children from their families at the
us-mexican border Melania Trump doesn't
like it she's hating to see it but of
course that's pretty carefully crafted
language just because you hate to see
something doesn't mean that you don't
think it's legally necessary for example
or is it yet another one of these public
disagreements on policy between Donald
Trump and Melania Trump number two we've
got a very interesting new study that
shows that on the one hand high school
students are less likely to be using
drugs or having sex than in previous
periods of time but they are also
increasingly feeling sad and hopeless
and I actually think that the same
explanation might be accurate for both
phenomena and thirdly we will talk about
a lawsuit against Harvard University
which claims that Asian American
applicants were scored lower on
personality traits by those evaluating
applications and that I think will be a
very very interesting discussion there
are two ways that you can get access to
the bonus show the first way is by
becoming a member at david pakman.com
slash membership or as I like to say
double you join pakman.com if the normal
prices strike you as high you can use
the coupon code vote soon 18 you don't
have to prove that the normal prices are
high you don't have to email me that
coupon code is available to you if you
want to save 40 percent use the coupon
code vote soon 18 you also can access
the world's famous bonus show by
becoming a patron at at least the $5 a
month level we now have all sorts of new
perks on patreon including free bumper
stickers coffee mugs getting listed as a
supporter on the 20-19 David Pakman show
calendar is a perk that we have
available so a lot of really really cool
stuff is available on patreon as well as
of course the bonus show and you can
find out more about that at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we have a
fantastic week of programs for you I
will be back in studio tomorrow and then
very very quickly we are coming up on
our 4th of July extravaganza which I
will tell you more about as we close in
on that day join pakman.com patreon.com
slash david pakman show don't miss
today's bonus show it's going to be a
really good one